welcome everybody to the final
installment of gain spots next big game
series all about no man's sky so far
this week our own intrepid explorer
Daniel Dwyer has told us about the story
behind the game but gameplay within
itself and also the crazy scale of the
universe but now it's my turn and for me
there's just one question that needs to
be answered how the bloody hell does it
all work
[Music]
the way the universe is created an
inland sky the way everything is graded
is this term that we use procedural
right and we're like really picky about
that where we say it's not random
right because random to me is this like
chaotic kind of mess potentially but
procedural is like creating mathematical
formulas right and they create a result
and the result is something that's the
psyche generated on the fly by the
computer but it's a result that
hopefully looks correct looks almost
like it's been built by hand
so rather than planets just being
randomly generated and us just picking
let's say a color for a planet
right once guy be red the next guy be
blue in the next guy me green and the
next guy be black or whatever you know
we don't do that because random
generation like that results in like an
entirely red planet with an entirely red
sky and looks terrible right so we
create algorithms that do things like
decide if a planet is in the right
distance from the Sun and if it is then
it would have water and so we generate
water on that planet and that creates
rivers and it creates lakes and oceans
potentially for then it also creates
moisture in the atmosphere then that
will affect the color of the sky because
the wavelength of the light is being
diffracted in different ways to create
different colors just like in in our
world now for me the key to the whole
universe and to understanding how it all
works is not to think about what happens
when you're there but instead to think
about what happens when you're not there
take the classic philosophical thought
experiment if a tree falls in the woods
and no one is around to hear it does it
make a sound
now in the real world most of us would
answer yes to this because of the
physical makeup of our observable
reality however in no man's sky the
answer is no because if no one's around
there is no tree there is no woods there
is no planet there's just nothing
as you fly around the world in the land
sky you might encounter say a mountain
and on that mountain there might be a
tree or a particular rock beside the
tree right and that is there and that
mountain is there and that tree is there
on top of the mountain because there is
effectively a mathematical formula and
the result of that formula will always
be the same so when you go and visit
that man you will always see that tree
there and if another player goes and
visits that same mountain they will see
that exact same tree in the exact same
place but it's not stored on the disk
it's not stored in the cloud and it's
just generated there and then on the fly
when you fly away we just throw that
data away we throw away their mountains
we throw away that tree and but if you
fly back it will be there again and
because it is just following this this
this pattern so every time you go
anywhere in your man's sky you're
essentially asking the game questions
math questions and the beauty of math
questions is the answer is always the
same so if you're the chord of no man's
sky and I ask you what's 45 plus 62 for
example the answer is always 107 doesn't
matter if I ask you now or next week or
in a year from now the answer will
always be the same as Shawn put it you
can think of it as putting in inputs and
getting out outputs so when you put in
the same inputs which is just I am here
at this point in the world you will
always get the same output which is the
mountain in that exact same position or
the rock that's on top of that mountain
down to the like blade of grass it will
always be in the exact same place if
another player comes along
they you know input the same inputs they
will get the same output
[Music]
the standard way to create the stuff of
videogames is to have designers and
artists build everything by hand terrain
creatures trees buildings everything you
see has been painstakingly crafted to a
higher level of detail
Nolan Skye handles detail differently
however once again everything is
generating
we generate everything at different logs
right which is like level of detail and
and level of detail is that thing that
gamers are used to you drive around GTA
and you will see a low detailed building
suddenly pop in and become a high detail
building hours don't don't pop but we
regenerate the entire planet but like
quite a low level of detail so when you
look up and you see it kind of hanging
there and then rising you can make out
mountains and hills and canyons and if
you get into your ship and you fly into
space and fly towards that planet as you
get closer and closer to it we will
generate higher and higher detail and as
you come in to land on it we begin to
generate like the highest levels of
detail but it's not just the details
that no man's sky can generate there's
also variety pretty much everything you
see plants trees spaceships and of
course the wildlife too is all unique
each one is literally one of a kind in
the entire universe how well it's kind
of like a character creation menu so
each base piece in the world be it a
dinosaur or a tree or spaceship or
whatever has the equivalent of little
sliders for every characteristic so for
the game to create variety all it needs
to do is move them
I just might create a caste and from
that cat they will also be creating
every type of lion and every type of
tiger but also things that are much more
kind of wild and and mutated from that
all of those creatures all of the ships
that you see in the sky and the
freighters and things like that they're
all following what we would call like a
fractal pattern so that means that
creatures will go down to the water and
drink some water and come back up to
higher ground and perhaps eat some grass
and go for a sleep so that some
creatures will only come out at night
all of those sort of things and they're
just again following like a mathematical
formula and so we don't simulate them
and that means that if you're on a
planet and you see a creature doing
something like that and then you fly
away and you come back it will be a
little bit further along that pattern
basically
the time I spent talking to Sean one
thing struck me over and over again
about the world they're creating due to
the layers and layers of simple
algorithms they've created a complicated
and mathematically chaotic system more
so than the sum of its parts and for me
this is the perfect example of chaos
theory changing just one thing in the
code has inherently unpredictable
results and this is what the challenge
that they need to overcome but also what
gets me so excited about the future of
no man's sky
[Music]
so I will make a rule that say there
should be little flowers around the base
of a tree right and I'll think that's a
good rule and then I like propagate that
to the main branch and suddenly there
are flowers around the base of every
tree unlike every planet right and
that's cool except it has like horrible
mouth guards right and I realized that
I'm an idiot that I'm not a god and this
was a terrible rule and suddenly all the
creatures are going crazy and they're
trying to eat around the base of trees
and they're eating flowers and things
like that and and so yeah you break the
universe horribly because you have this
this ridiculous power you've got loads
of simple rules they all each has a
cause and effect but you find it
impossible to predict what they're gonna
result in because there's a whole bunch
of even just with like half a dozen
rules it suddenly becomes really hard to
predict what's gonna happen
[Music]